hello and welcome to this video on
playing yeah let's go something I cannot
do it I want to do something else and he
plays a wacky benoni but just for
variety's sake let's play some other
opening it's an interesting interesting
line often leading to complex strategic
positions it's not believed to be a yeah
great for white but so kind of
interesting that looks a lot like a wood
Fisher games from the 1960s against
people like Petrosian Fisher didn't
score in those games absolutely not but
it's still kept playing this variation
yeah here also after your 5 black should
be okay shooting for f/4g 5 is an
interesting move maybe well it's a bit
early maybe a bit early fun to go for
that
okay so i can i can beg you at five that
is for that attack but I don't have a
half the bishops of that anymore so I've
got some some doubts if that's a sound
strategy how to do it
put it on age three-year a bishop
not sure that it does so much on age
three but the the way it is currently
positioned it's not not great either
yeah I guess he played it well the
opening this cannot be great for white
but yeah I'm not an expert on the line
just wanted to do something else Oh
interesting and so he takes it as it's
surprising I mean age 4 is certainly um
yeah it looks like something that could
that could encourage their capture but
still my bishop now it's looking like a
a piece that has some scope and it
wasn't clear at all that this ever would
happen okay um yeah take it or not
yeah I mean 94 I can play for 96
b 5 9650 six ed six attacks the Queen so
in 96 is a threat winning some material
now okay h4 is hanging can also take
take the 5 10 96 takes pawn takes Queen
takes rook takes hmm i don't have
anything at the end okay so and over 2g
for now 96 is definitely in the mix not
easy for me to play this position
yeah but d5 is hanging and this is the
thing isn't that important 55 and then
what Rupe Teague's d6 still it takes I
don't don't quite get it night you
wonders night f5 and kill I think
now I think I'm winning now I'd have
five what did I overlooked something the
thing is that key Queen f-89 age 6 s
just devastating we should have seven
also was waiting I guess this is what I
had seen earlier and it should this side
made on g7 the queen is saying will
check and Queen f-89 h6 win styles
black resins a tough position I really
definitely was in good shape outside of
the opening this is something that looks
a lot like those old Fisher games and
Fisher didn't had a good positions with
white said he really didn't okay that
looks off fairly logical I think and now
I went to this age for move Jim I'm not
actually sure that this just does that
much if he just continues with yeah I
know be five or something that kind of
belongs into the position Jim but he
took and I don't think this is a great
idea maybe from for technical reasons
yeah that that might be but on general
considerations I'm giving me the
opportunity to push me five and all of a
sudden open up my bishop is a bit looks
questionable the computer wants to do
this and put the night here interesting
and then f6 with a quality but this is
the kind of equality that is not going
to be equal for a long time Erica
probably something very sharp is going
to happen yet making quite some sense
okay now we had this this up here 95 lat
c4i are so critical and he went over
there Queen g4 is the best move
according to the engine that's good yeah
and now probably this is the thing okay
I computer wants to play f5 or f6 also
quite a nice idea and this is that wrong
no it's not wrong but ok well this
losses but he could have played here
I was thinking that this this this
should be quite okay for me which it is
but you can actually after work chase te
this maybe is also on and check yeah
tougher but this this is lose right
between five and over yeah the thing is
set here check check check near white
winsome check quite a bit of material
janice and so on yeah and it looks nice
the night has stolen a good job here
eating eating all of the rooks yeah a
bit of them garikai record the lucky win
but it was a bit of a bit of a sudden
wind and say if he is not blundering
this he's okay still a very tense
position probably there needs to be some
improvement needs to be played out and
did the opening here because i don't
have the good position there but okay
well i'm not an expert okay thanks for
watching